imagine that you're building a really
scalable app an app like this needs to
be built on a powerful database that is
scalable highly available and globally
distributed you're wondering which
database to use then a thought crosses
your mind let's see which one Google is
using their apps really scale you
discover that Google products such as
ads photos and Gmail use a database
called spanner spanner is a no
compromise globally consistent database
that offers high performance and
availability at virtually unlimited
scale it automatically chars your data
to optimize for performance as you grow
that sounds great so you decide to use
it too but now the entire company wants
access to the data your CEO wants an
application usage report every week then
every day the analytics team starts
streaming the data from spanner into
their data warehouse the AI team starts
pulling data for generative AI training
if everybody piles on like that the
database and the the app could slow down
you can't take that risk you can easily
scale up spanner but that wouldn't be
cost effective you can limit these data
pulls to off peak hours but nobody wants
steal data what to do spanner offers a
clever solution called Data boost we
describe it as data sharing done right
if a query uses a large amount of CPU
scanning over a large portion of the
data it's a good fit here's how it works
queries using data boost run on entirely
separate compute resources from spanner
these resources are always on always
ready to run queries and you only pay
for what you use you can set usage
limits at the user and query level for
granular cost control this workload
isolation means analytical queries have
virtually no impact on transactional
queries both types run predictably
because they don't compete for resources
data boost is also secure all your
existing access control and data
governance rules are still enforced
spanner data boost provides worry-free
analytical and batch processing that
doesn't impact database performance and
security run as many reports as you want
a report every day let's make that once
an hour upgrade your analytical queries
whether they originate from Big query
Federated queries or a pipeline you've
set up to use datab boost until your AI
team they can run as much training as
they need finally your entire
organization can get value from your
data create a spanner database powered
by data boost or enable it for your
existing database there are links for
more info in the description
below